I thought I had covet about three times
I'm one of those idiots I was like I
think I have it
can you feel
I'm bad with pain too like the other day
I hit my elbow right on that spot where
if I had a gun I'd be dead now you know
that's I
I do paint that's why I could never be a
cop I couldn't walk around with a gun
right here there's 50 things a day where
I'd be like [ __ ] that that ain't worth
thank you
that's my main problem by the way with
the whole defund the police idea
what about people that want to commit
suicide by cop what about them
anyway we'll put a pin in that but
we had a lot of protests in New York and
now we have protesters that just live
here
they're not out of protest they're just
here
I saw a protester in Washington Square
Park she had green hair and dirty legs
foreign
she's holding a little piece of
cardboard
and it's with a sharpie it said abolish
billionaires
which is standing there
and I thought I don't think it's gonna
do it
I feel like that's gonna result
and Jeff Bezos what's happening
sadly
it's gonna be okay for him
I think I thought it was good how young
people got out there and they expressed
themselves they went out there to solve
a lot of problems not all problems but
some of them
they they went out there to stop
discrimination
not all discrimination
just some of it which is a weird form of
discrimination but there are groups
there are groups that are discriminated
against who don't have any protesters or
any people working for them and we all
discriminate against these people like
ugly people everybody discriminates
against ugly people they do and it's
awful I mean I'd rather be discreeting
it against for my race than for being
ugly
the job or a promotion but nobody kids
you on the lips like your whole [ __ ]
life like like try that
this is what we say to ugly people we
don't like your faith
just don't like it
so no one's gonna fall in love with you
and it's unanimous sorry
and we just expect ugly people to be
like oh no I understand I mean sure it's
my head shape is no good for you so I'll
I'll with I'll go without the things
that matter in life
foreign
also overweight people overweight people
deal with things that none of us deal
with because I'm not overweight
who are discriminated against again
because of their weight I read a story
once about a woman who's 600 pounds and
she couldn't get medical care because
everything she goes to the doctor he
just says it's because she's fat
everything she's like my knees hurt he's
like yeah my knees hurt just looking at
you what'd you think was gonna happen
she's like I have chest pains he says
yeah because your organs are over
capacity so they're hurting
she's like I got shot in the head he
said yeah cause you're [ __ ] fat
somebody shot you in the [ __ ] head
because you're fat
it's a terrible story
here's the worst part of the story and
this is this is true this is true she
needed an MRI
because she had some serious she's 600
pounds she doesn't fit in the machine
you know what they did they sent her to
the zoo I'm not kidding they sent her
the [ __ ] zoo
that's what we do for fat people
we need an MRI
okay here's your prescription
go to the zoo
yeah that's where you should go you
should go to the zoo
by the way you know how many fat people
we have in this country about 600
trillion billion thousands of them
you know how many trans people there are
about 38.
but if you're trans and you need a
restroom and it's awkward we'll change
every restroom but if you're fat and
need an MRI you go to the zoo you fat
[ __ ] thank you
just go to the zoo
you go experience that today
what happens when she gets to the zoo
actually [ __ ] happens
when she arrives at the zoo
hi
are you here to see the monkeys no I'm
here for an MRI
oh [ __ ] all right yeah uh-huh okay just
stand in the straw over here
yeah you're after the walrus who has
lymphoma
by the way why is there an MRI machine
at the [ __ ] zoo
what was it developing that instead of a
fat human being am I right who's paying
for this [ __ ] you don't give an elephant
a [ __ ] magnetic resonance image test
[ __ ] high that's obscene
if an elephant is sick you just listen
you do this thing
Misa thinks she's gonna die today
I'm saying this out of respect for
Elephants by the way because we're
supposed to respect how they live they
don't [ __ ] cure their diseases this
is not their culture this is our word
let's fix it oh he's sick that's not how
elephants live an elephant in the
Serengeti isn't like I have a lump I
have to see my oncologist
foreign
gets cancer he falls over he takes his
[ __ ] turn and becomes food
what an elephant in a state-of-the-art
what if you find cancer what are you
gonna give him chemotherapy
skinny elephant with a pink baseball hat
[Applause]
each day is a gift
to the ladies talking about body issues
they're always talking about body issues
that's the dumbest one ever when they
talk about Hollywood going like
Hollywood they create these impossible
body Images blah blah you know that
whole thing the plus size actress right
the fatties
yeah
that's like a big thing them they're
sick of being treated like fat people
I don't know what it is they're doing
they're going on the cover of magazines
now just like showing how fat they are
we're in a little bit of amount of
clothes and everybody's like hyping them
up like oh my God that's so brave that's
so courageous
I'm not saying it doesn't take balls but
that's a bit of an overreach with the
word brave
right
like what am I supposed to do if I ever
see a fireman running out of a building
carrying a baby and an old lady am I
going to sit there like oh my God you're
like a fat actress that takes her shirt
off to do a magazine shoot to promote
the movie she's in
now look I know you're not supposed to
make fun of fat people I understand all
right I don't know why though
why they're not a race they're not a
religion it's totally curable eat an
apple and go for a walk you know why are
you yelling at everybody else
the [ __ ] are you giving me [ __ ] for all
right you put the cookies in there I
didn't
how is this my problem
Jesus Christ you ain't your way in you
can walk your way out all right and just
slowly start shedding the pounds shove
some [ __ ] lettuce in there instead of
a bunch of ho-hos and it's it's gonna
come down
and then you're on my side of the fence
right join me come on stay with me Shame
Shame
shame right
I know you're not supposed to shame
you're not supposed to Fat shame you're
not supposed to [ __ ] shame
they're like shaming shaming
like people aren't supposed to walk
around with any shame it's like a
legitimate human emotion but you're not
supposed to feel it at all you know it's
just walking around like a dictator just
not you know not gonna feel any shame
you never felt shame
you never had such a bad [ __ ] night
the next morning you woke up you
couldn't even look yourself in the
mirror when you went to go brush your
teeth you looked up you're like uh you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] wow wow even for
you that was bad lights out curtains
drawn until at least two in the
afternoon before I can even look at you
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
yeah you're supposed to have no shame
that's the new world you're just gonna
walk around sucking dick you know eating
cookies and just show up and nobody's
supposed to say anything no one's
supposed to have an opinion like wow
that's that's going to go off the rails
pretty soon
I know it's probably mean to do this
stuff but like you can only have so much
sympathy there's so much so much stuff
he can care about you know what happened
to me that changed my life I did a gig
in India right unbelievably great people
but some of the stuff that I saw there
I'll never forget I literally I did a
gig in India I saw a toddler take a [ __ ]
between two parked cars walked away no
pants or parents and then disappeared
into the crowd like Hannibal Lecter at
the end of Silence of the lamps
it's one of the most heartbreaking
things I've ever seen in my life and
then I come back to my country and it's
like oh the studio said I lose 50 pounds
to star in a movie when it start running
you fat [ __ ]
it's your big complaint in life
you know what it you know it is you know
what it is about these fatties you know
what it really is
they have no respect for the amount of
sacrifice and dedication it takes to
truly get in like magazine level shape
which is that you ever try to get abs
you ever try to get all the ABS and get
that [ __ ] down here you ever try to do
it it's [ __ ] impossible
past the age of 19 you can't do it
without tons of help you're going to buy
all these exercise tapes you got to read
about nutrition you got to get a
personal trainer having you [ __ ]
running along
you need like your own chef and he's
like okay don't eat it yet don't eat it
yet all right now eat it start consuming
it all right start slow down stop stop
I told you to stop
oh you like that Brussels sprout did you
like that brush up cause now you're
paying for it
it's a [ __ ] miserable experience
just walking around your whole body's
eating yourself you know you want some
cake now
just take a salad
balsamic vinaigrette on the side no
croutons
oh my God what is the photo shoot I want
to kill myself
it's horrible
you ever try to get fat
no
you don't have to it's effortless you
can [ __ ] lay on your back watching
your favorite show just shoveling [ __ ]
down your throat what are you doing I'm
getting fat I'm getting fat you got a
trainer don't need one it's natural
I just eat everything that makes my
sugar salt go like yeah
[Applause]
yeah comes right in nice roll of [ __ ] a
[ __ ] lab
no it's ridiculous like I know nobody
wants to be fat so I'm not [ __ ] on
you about that but don't [ __ ] come at
me like it's my problem and I need to
[ __ ] rewire myself no you're
overweight okay there's plenty of things
that can help you out
this is everybody's got something to
deal with I'm a [ __ ] lunatic with my
temper this is something I have to deal
with I do you know you you can't [ __ ]
stop eating pork chops that's something
you have to [ __ ] deal with I don't
have to completely rewire myself
you know what is it's just a bunch of
sixes pissed off that they're not
getting treated like a 10. you know at
some point you just got to acknowledge
what you are you're a six I'm sorry all
right nobody jerks off to a six that's a
deal
unless you work with them you work with
them you know she's got that one outfit
you know it just does something for you
you're working Close Quarters so this
you know what a shampoo smells like it's
an intimacy there's an intimacy there
all right
I don't know what women rub one out too
but I know it ain't me all right this is
a fantasy that's why I don't feel bad
about
trashing them it's like yeah this is all
coming from I'm a strong five all right
that's where I am so I still feel like
I'm punching up here you know
honestly people I'm a bald redheaded
male you don't think there's a glass
ceiling on the kinds of parts I can get
in Hollywood really
you think I'm never going to be the lead
in a romantic comedy
that ain't happening here if I'm booking
the movie I want to make the money back
that's the thing that's it's Show
Business there's a million dollars on
this film okay we're trying to make
[ __ ] money you just want to show up
with [ __ ] crumbs on the side of your
face
show up in shape looking as [ __ ] as
possible know your lines
ready to work it's called being a
professional right
dude [ __ ] Bachelor had abs and meet the
parents there was no reason for him to
do that he just knew I'm gonna take my
[ __ ] shirt off I don't want to get
trashed
it was shredded
yeah go be a [ __ ] Postman I mean I
don't know what to tell you all right
now you know what it is this is just the
ramblings of someone who's sliding in to
the back nine of his life and I'm not
understanding
half the [ __ ] that's going on you know
but you know one of the big things that
really made me feel old was when
McDonald's started making salads
that literally ripped my heart out I'm
like they're doing what what
now they have wraps
and they're doing all of this [ __ ] you
know what it was was I shape people
complain to them so you're like oh you
don't have any healthy options it's like
dude this is McDonald's
this [ __ ] is poison
who the [ __ ] comes here to get in shape
whenever I get McDonald's I have a whole
plan at my age I'm 48 years old I know
what I'm gonna order I'm gonna go in
there it's gonna taste great 20 minutes
later I'm going to want to kill myself
and then I'm gonna go to the gym
tomorrow I'm going to the gym tomorrow
and no matter how much I say that I woke
up the demon in me I woke up to demon
and all that grease is just coursing
through my veins and no matter how much
I want to go to the gym there's going to
be this other voice going dude get an
Egg McMuffin go down there and get an
Egg McMuffin I'm gonna sit up like The
Manchurian Candidate okay we're going to
McDonald's it's my In-Shape voice it's
in the background no what are we doing
I'm just
gonna drive right down right I know what
it is
but somehow ought to shape people
somehow got that made them dare to
[ __ ] blame they had to have more
healthy [ __ ] because they're the reason
why everybody's fat how come they have
to do it what about Ben and Jerry's how
come they don't have to put a little
kale in their ice cream why is that oh
cause they're a couple of hippies man
you're like making ice cream
they're going after big bad McDonald's
you know it's just
who the [ __ ] goes to McDonald's to get
in shape
don't give me that horseshit that eating
healthy is is is expensive it isn't go
to a [ __ ] Supermarket they're
throwing the vegetables at you here's
celery get it the [ __ ] out of here
since 25 cents for a banana whatever the
[ __ ] you want get it out of here
before it goes bad
no it's [ __ ] up they somehow convinced
them that that you know
McDonald's is the reason why I'm out of
shape
I would have got a salad but you didn't
have the option so I was like well I
guess I got to get 52 Big Macs
thanks a lot McDonald's it's like dude
you're an adult it's not their job to
babysit you they're a [ __ ] business
if you want a 50 sandwiches they're
gonna give it to you it's your job to
not do it you [ __ ] dope right
wow
sorry
I know yeah
dude McDonald's McDonald's exists for
two reasons okay it's for drunk people
and it's for children all right that's
what this thing is you know you're in
your car your kids won't shut the hell
up you go to the drive-through you go to
the drive-through you get a couple of
poison Burgers you throw it down their
throats their little systems can't
handle it they start
I've nodding off
and you're up front you're bigger you
can handle a bigger dose of poison you
know what I mean pop in your Def Leppard
cassette you have a little moment for
yourself
yeah
that's what it's for
it's for your kids and it's for drunk
people like how many times have you
driven out to a bar going I'm just gonna
have one all of a sudden you had like 11
right and you hammered and you're
thinking but you know but you're
responsible
you're drunk but you're responsible
you're like God damn it I drove my car
here tonight
God damn it I'm driving it up all right
I'm not gonna burden this place of
business by taking up a parking space
and this completely empty parking lot
for the next six hours
I'm not advocating drinking and driving
but I will tell you there's nothing
better than when all your friends and
family know you hammered there's nothing
better than that walk to the car it's
incredible women are screaming people
tearing at your clothes you feel like
you're in the Beatles oh
I'm like no autographs
sorry I have to have to go I'll be back
get him off me
and you kiss you get in the car and
everybody's screaming getting the
[ __ ] car you're fine I had a car
eight years I know I can almost see my
house just get in the [ __ ] car
you gotta make the cops come get in the
[ __ ] I swear to God just get in the
[ __ ] car
I'll take your seat belt off you [ __ ]
Mary I'm going right down the street
right
and then what happens you get out on the
road you realize you're way more
hammered than you thought who was always
there for you McDonald's with the
drive-through the 24-hour drive-through
you could just pull in and hide in plain
sight right and that little sad traffic
jam of divorcees shut-ins people who go
to Comic-Con right you just pull in
and just stop you can take a little nap
it's like damn thank you thank you
you pull around that's what it was all
about and all of a sudden they're the
reason this country's out of shape you
know they've had McDonald's my whole
life people weren't this [ __ ] fat
right it's not their fault you can't pin
it on them but McDonald's [ __ ] up they
[ __ ] up because they gave in to out of
shape people and they said all right
fine fine it's our fault we'll start
making salads and then they got on their
heels they got on their heels everybody
sensed it and now look at them okay four
or five years later now they got to make
they gotta make breakfast all day right
because you know what happened all the
potheads showed up going well hey man if
you're going to make him a salad like
like what if I want like a breakfast
thingy and it's like it's not breakfast
like
you're gonna hook him up but you're not
gonna hook me up that's
that's like food racism or something man
I I just don't understand like fine
we'll start making we'll make the
breakfast they just completely lost
their way
I swear to god dude if I was running
that Corporation this is what I would do
you know what I would do I bring that
clown back
all right
I bring the cloud back okay and I just
have that thing just look right down the
barrel of the camera have a little bit
of dry ice in the background you just
come right in tight on his face
it just looks right in the camera and
just goes look
if you can't get your fat ass down here
by 10 30 in the morning
you're getting a burger
all right
the clown ain't finished
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not making pancakes at three o'clock
in the afternoon because you did blow
all night with your friends and you're
just getting your [ __ ] together all
right
make no mistake this is a burger joint
it's always been a burger joint we did
that breakfast thing as a favor you know
we were just trying to freak out IHOP
we're doing it too we're doing it too
your own mother won't make your pancakes
at three o'clock in the afternoon okay
so get your fat ass or your drugged up
ass down here before 10 30. we decide
it's our place we tell you what the [ __ ]
we're making all right
take them out and he pushes a kid on the
swing something nice